can't resist trashing trump in his white
house cnn's jake tapper getting called
out
for saying this about white house press
secretary kaley mcinerney
there are some people that are such um
they're just so mendacious
i just wouldn't put them on air um
kaylee mcenany i i never booked her uh
jason miller from uh the trump campaign
i would never book him i mean these are
just people who just
they just tell lies the way that you
know most people breathe
and there is no value in that there's a
big difference between somebody like
kaylee mcinney who just like
this is what she does she tells lies all
the time she can't acknowledge reality
so i'm just not i'm just not going to
put somebody like that on air
kaylee mackley responding on twitter
saying
this is therapy this is a therapy
session for a broken network
all right guys let me ask you this um is
this
super hypocrisy saying that oh
she's a liar or is it until they turn
on the president because we know there's
quite a few cnn
jobs available for you if you leave the
white house under
angry terms you end up as a special
guest on cnn pretty regularly
scaramucci cohen etc the list goes on
and on
my question emily for you is it
hypocrisy or is there any truth in what
he's saying
i think there is absolute hypocrisy and
also tyrus i think this is the streisand
effect
all over again right by them naming
their beast
and continuing to obsess over their
beast they are all still and we are all
still
talking about it right and the obsession
is totally evident you know despite
their
better than thou attitude and everything
that they're trying to put out there
their advertising dollars at those
networks are still being spent on the
topic
of president trump and what i don't
understand too is what is their
perceived benefit
the president-elect has been named it's
joe biden
so what is it to them that they are
continuing to spend these advertising
dollars and their time talking about
this administration why wouldn't they be
focused on the incoming one
i think it's pretty obvious why well
yeah ratings matter
lisa let me ask you this isn't the whole
point of the interview
is determined for the american people to
figure out whether someone's lying or
telling the truth
is it really up to the to the
broadcaster well i think the irony here
is that people like jake tapper and many
of the liberals that work in the media
have protected
the most prolific liar in american
political history
which is joe biden i mean if you look at
joe biden's history he lies about
everything he's a plagiarist he lied
about his family coming from coal miners
he lied about receiving
the naacp's endorsement even though they
don't endorse he's lied about things
like graduating in the top of his
law school he's lied about everything
yet the media
didn't vet him they they protected him
and his son's lies and his business
dealings from that information getting
out
to the american people and i think the
entire reason why the media hates
president trump so much
is he doesn't buy into their bs
narratives that they push
for instance you know people like mitt
romney with the war on women he said
look
in response to that i have binders full
of women he played along with it whereas
president trump if he gets a question
like that he just says wrong
you know move on and ignores it so he
just doesn't buy
in he doesn't placate the left in the bs
narratives
that they have always pushed and they
continue to push
mary uh you're the staunch democrat in
the room so
uh you know it tends to look one-sided
sometimes but don't you think both sides
are pretty guilty
of wanting to hear the voice that agrees
with them do you think that happens way
too much in today's
news network or opinion channels
well sure but also as someone who has
stood at a podium and had to represent
the government
answering reporter questions we always
saw our job democrat or
republican as telling the truth giving
information and the media has had to
deal with
donald trump a president for the first
time in my lifetime certainly
who lies every single day multiple times
a day
who has no sense of reality at many
times
and people like kaylee mcinerney who i
know and and have liked for a long
time who goes on tv and says things that
are demonstrably false
how do you deal with that how do you
fact check that in real time that's a
great question
that you can't fact check everything on
on an interview so you just don't book
them
but this is a challenge for reporters
for the first time we've seen a
president
and his staff blatantly outright
not telling the truth it's dangerous
benghazi lied about the iran deal as
well i mean take a look at some of the
things joe biden
said in the previous fight
you've been behind enemy lines you've
been on the back deals of this you've
seen it without the cameras
take us home make some sense of this
it's getting rough in here
listen i love left-wing media and how
seriously they take themselves
these are the media networks that put on
eric swalwell and adam schiff and
michael avenatti the ones that failed to
report on joe
and hunter biden's laptop and foreign
payments they're the ones that undermine
the president's
commitment that a vaccine would come out
before the end of the year that actually
happened they spent two years on russia
collusion
i don't believe anything they say and uh
the news is not on news networks anymore
especially in liberal
media land boom that's how you do it
that's why
i knew sean i knew you'd take it home
for me